the key pattern that you've already sort
of cottoned onto
is f dash on f right that's what i'm
searching for okay
now you've already identified you're
like oh i
i don't want 10x cubed i want 20x cubed
where does that come from and the answer
is
if f of x really is 5x to the 4 minus 7x
squared plus 8 right
then f dash should be what what should
it be
of the denominator 20 uh 20 x to the
power of three
and minus uh 14
x to the power of nothing uh plus
eight well to the power one but yeah
plus eight plus eight
that is gone it's gone right because you
differentiate it
and it's disappeared okay good so that's
what i want that's what i want and you
can see it is suspiciously close to what
i've got
in fact what i've got is exactly half
the size
it's exactly half the size and what
you'll find is it is often like this the
numerator if we want to make it easy
relatively easy we will make that top
thing a um
an integer multiple or an integer
proportion of it right okay so all right
let's
let's unpack that right so you said just
put brackets and a 2
right which gives me this like so
all divided by let's let's be
exceptionally lazy
here we go yeah that that is super lazy
okay yeah i'm trying to be efficient
okay now we've put this two here
but you can't just make it twice as big
because you want to because it's
convenient to you
on the outside does if i put two on the
outside
this is still not equivalent to what i
started with right
do you remember when i put a um and it's
admittedly like i kind of walked right
into this right
when i showed you this example here i
wanted a minus sign
that's because they cancel that ah yes
very good so these two cancel out
what i want is for the 2 and whatever i
put out the front to cancel out
which is indeed a half does that make
sense
so now you can see these two together
those two things i've highlighted in
pink
don't actually result in any net change
you still have the same thing okay
now now i'm ready to go so that half
hanging out the front it's just
hanging out the front and now what uh
you expand the top which is just going
to be the diff of the bottom
you don't really have to do that it's
just going to waste time yeah you
already know you already know it's going
to be the
um the 20 x cubed minus 14 x you're
headed right so let's let's not write
the integral again we're
helen absolute brackets
yep fantastic like so
yep close it and then
done that's it that wasn't hard at all
um in fact you know sometimes it's one
of the things about
mathematics right it's you know real
life lesson like people
hear and see mathematical things all the
time and they respond the same way we
did when we looked at it like ah
you're like i don't do this and then we
just kind of
the danger of that of course is we just
accept whatever it is that people say on
the basis of that
without understanding right and then
you're like actually if i just pushed a
little bit
i could have understood it and then i
would be able to um
i'll be able to scrutinize or critique
the situation and the conclusions you
draw from it
for myself rather just accept what you
said which happens all the time
so that's why it's worth pushing past
that initial
gross feeling see if you can work with
that and is there any other twists that
i should keep in mind
um okay so
[Music]
i mean the main twists if i had done
this again i would have actually done
this slightly in reverse order
the main twist is that sometimes this
happens
right whereby the top isn't the
derivative of the bottom and it will and
it will and it never will be
even when you multiply or divide or
whatever what you need is actually to
separate it completely into two
integrals
and then you can see one of them ends up
being um one of them ends up being a log
and then okay it turns into something
completely different right and that does
happen
um did you do that with any number
when you say do with any number force it
into
um a normal polynomial um it depends
so if for example it completely depends
on what you get handed
it up so if i gave you this right
um this guy up the top
it all comes from the derivative of this
guy down the bottom
right so if you were to try and break it
up suppose you took the 10x cubed term
and just separated out from the minus
seven x
right what you'd then end up with you're
like oh i'm stuck
like there's no way i can take those
things separately and get an integral
out of them i need them together
to be um f dash yeah don't worry about
it too much
um but yes you what you just need to
watch for is like
if you can turn it into f dash like we
did like you did
it'll be fairly apparent fairly quickly
if you can't you'd be like oh there's an
extra thing hanging out here i've got to
do something else with it
okay interesting
i feel like we should call it unless you
have a burning question you wanted to
have a look at uh no it's just a
clarification here but
you don't have to try it no it's fine
when you have that uh x-axis and you
have like that dip
in the graph and then you're like find
that when
i'm gonna draw something you said you
said
when you've got um axes yeah and a
parabola that dips under where like that
yeah and you're trying to find this
what's the question
uh is it under the curve
that's a good question um so
okay all right so so suppose
uh this was a function of some kind
right it doesn't even need to be a
parabola
okay and your job was to find um
this area here okay um
your question was is that the area
under the curve now it's a good question
because strictly speaking
that's above the curve right like it's
just above
area under a curve is is kind of a
colloquial is not the right word but
it's kind of like a it's it's a bit of a
shorthand for saying
what it really means is the area bounded
between the curve
and an axis right i don't know if you
remember this but
one of the graphs we looked at looked
like this and we actually said you know
what
i want to find this area over here it's
not above no
it's not below right it wasn't the
online class so the point here
is actually integration enables you to
find any area
bounded to any axis right it doesn't
have to be above or below it doesn't
need to be left or right whichever way
you want right
so area under a curve the reason why we
say that is because the most frequent
kind of area that we get
is an area underneath the curve but the
technical way to say this
is it's the area bounded between the
curve
and the x-axis you even have to say
x-axis because as we saw in this example
could be it could be the y-axis
yeah and the way you do that is just
draw a
um rectangle
are you talking about are you talking
about this one here yeah minus the
theoretical value of that rectangle with
the
known curve which you just made up it it
depends entirely on
what that curve happens to be so the
example i gave you
for that for this one over here was
actually y equals log x
and the reason why i looked to the left
hand side in the first place was because
i don't know how to integrate log
x actually i don't know how within the
scope of this course right so i'm like
i can't i can't do this right
right right so what i can do though
is that i can integrate with respect to
like this is y equals log x
which if i rephrase it as x equals e to
the y
i can integrate e to the y with respect
to y
these end up being related
interconnected questions
but i can integrate this one even though
i can't integrate this one
which becomes one well either y just
becomes in the y
plus a constant and then if you want
this particular area you just put in
some boundaries and then off you go
boundaries and then you put in the
boundaries of a rectangle and then minus
that correct
would you be able to um because my first
instinct was to
rotate uh you can do that too you
absolutely can do that too you change
the whole equation
so yeah i mean the reason why um i
actually used to teach
this particular problem like that the
reason why
i no longer do that is for two reasons
number one um
you are dramatically redefining the
question you're like
i don't like this question here's a
here's another one which is easy for me
to solve it is equivalent
same but different right um but but the
thing is if you're going to do something
like that you must justify it
very very carefully and specifically
because you're like here's this other
great problem i solved you're like yeah
great
there's another problem i wanted you to
solve right so if you're going to do
that you can't um
you know you can't muck around with that
you've got to be very specific
that's the first reason i don't like to
do it the second reason is
the way that you can do it without
redefining the way i just described
considering as an area bounded to the
y-axis
you've got to know how to do that anyway
so it's like well i might as well teach
you
by by way of this question